[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de 100% Sénat
l'émission qui vous fait vivre les
travaux de la Haute Assemblée la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur la
pénurie de médicaments poursuit ses
auditions les sénateurs ont entendu
Olivier Véran l'actuel porte-parole du
gouvernement et ancien ministre de la
Santé durant le premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron l'occasion de
l'interroger sur les causes récentes de
l'actuelle pénurie de médicaments je
vous laisse écouter cette audition
je remercie le Sénat d'assurer ce
travail d'enquête car il est toujours
utile de se pencher sur cette question
qui certes n'est pas nouvelle mais qui
est qui a été au cœur de l'actualité cet
hiver elle est encore aujourd'hui elle
sera peut-être encore hélas tout autant
demain il faut en croire en effet il
faut croire en effet et je parle ici en
tant qu'observateur que les pénuries
viendront à s'accélérer pour preuve
différents éléments d'abord le
vieillissement de la population à
l'échelle de notre pays et de l'Europe
on vit plus longtemps c'est une bonne
chose mais on vit plus longtemps avec
des maladies chroniques on a appris à
vivre avec ce qui est aussi une bonne
chose mais pour y arriver nous
consommons des médicaments de plus en
plus de médicaments j'y viendrai tout à
l'heure trop de médicaments
la demande va continuer d'augmenter ces
mécanique
l'offre qui répond à cette demande c'est
celle de l'industrie qui part nature à
un impact sur l'environnement j'en
parlerai tout à l'heure parce que quand
on parle d'introduire des usines de
production de médicaments et j'avais eu
l'occasion de le dire à des
parlementaires lorsque j'étais ministre
en charge on parle d'usine qui sont
souvent pétrochimiques avec des sites et
vaisseaux tout le monde veut qu'on
produise des médicaments dans le pays
mais c'est plus compliqué de trouver les
endroits où l'implanter et que ça fasse
consensus et on peut le comprendre sans
oublier sans omettre le fait que la
transition écologique nous oblige aussi
à faire des choix très raisonnés en
matière de production industrielle
j'aborde même pas la question du coût de
production j'espère que c'est
conjoncturel et la consommation
énergétique de ces industries tente à
peser fortement sur le dynamisme de
l'offre surtout lorsqu'elle se fait
appris constant et j'y reviendrai là
aussi nous avons donc d'un côté une
offre qui pourrait être contrainte
pendant que la demande elle accélèrerait
c'était là le scénario idéal si je peux
me permettre le mot pour que des
pénuries continuent de se multiplier
surtout je souhaiterais avant d'entrer
dans le vif du sujet apporter une autre
précision qui me semble de taille il
faudrait pas laisser croire à nos
concitoyens que le gouvernement découvre
le sujet d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit en
introduction et je vous en remercie nous
avons commencé à voir la croissance des
pénuries de médicaments car nous avons
commencé à les mesurer
les déclarations obligatoires auprès de
l'ANSM pour les tensions et les ruptures
de médicaments ont donné à avoir un état
au vrai d'une situation qui était sans
doute très imparfaitement mesuré jusqu'à
jusqu'à lors des choses ont été faites
en partie lorsque j'étais ministre mais
pas seulement en ma qualité de
parlementaire déjà j'ai eu à connaître
des textes et réflexions portées par
d'autres gouvernements que celui auquel
j'appartiens aujourd'hui c'est bien
qu'en matière de lutte contre les
pénuries de médicaments la France
dispose d'un cadre juridique
particulièrement robuste et protecteur
que nombre de nos voisins nous envient
j'interviendrai aujourd'hui autour de
trois points non pas 4 madame la
Présidente mais trois points qui me
semblent aussi bien traduire le sens de
mon action en tant que ministre de la
Santé quatre des éléments de réflexion
et de prospection précieux à garder à
l'esprit pour comprendre la situation du
médicament aujourd'hui d'abord je vous
présenterai la feuille de route
j'aborderai la feuille de route
2019-2022 que j'ai piloté en tant que
ministre et participer à enrichir avant
d'être ministre lorsque j'étais
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale ensuite et c'est une évidence
mais je reviendrai avec vous sur la
crise du covid-19 et dans quelle mesure
elle a été dans sa dimension sanitaire
comme économique un accélérateur et un
catalyseur autant de la pénurie du
médicament que dans notre feuille de
route pour lutter contre la pénurie
enfin je terminerai sur des
considérations à moyen et long terme sur
l'avenir du médicament de sa production
à son recyclage en passant naturellement
par son usage en France et en Europe
commençons donc par le commencement la
feuille de route
2019-2022 elle a été pensée et lancée
dans un contexte qui est différent en
tout de ce que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui après avoir traversé la
crise sanitaire dans le caractère inédit
dans l'histoire contemporaine n'a
peut-être eu d'égal que sa violence pour
nos sociétés
pourtant déjà je m'en souviens sur les
bancs de l'Assemblée nationale le sujet
des pénuries de médicaments étaient un
sujet de préoccupation en 2019 le
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe s'est
emparé du sujet en effet on relève qu'en
10 ans de 2008 à 2018 les signalements
de pénurie ont été multipliés par 20 ce
qui était un Ferrari Sims semblait pour
des raisons que vous connaissez mais sur
lesquelles nous pourrons revenir devenir
une tendance de fond durable en France
et en Europe je vais d'ailleurs là une
assise la situation et les constats ne
se limite pas au seul hexagone
l'ensemble de nos voisins sont aussi
concernés
face à l'enjeu l'ambition et la volonté
d'anticipation du Premier ministre se
sont traduites en acte dans la feuille
de route ambitieuse qui a été pilotée
par Agnès Buzyn puis par votre serviteur
cette feuille de route est visée ainsi
quatre objectifs prioritaires on y vient
promouvoir la transparence et la qualité
de l'information améliorer la gestion et
la sécurisation de l'ensemble de la
chaîne du médicament renforcer la
coopération européenne mettre en place
une nouvelle gouvernance nationale au
service de ces objectifs 28 actions ont
été déployées dans le contexte contraint
que vous connaissez 7 groupes de travail
se sont régulièrement réunis pour
proposer des mesures concrètes je vous
ferai pas la litanie de l'ensemble des
actions menées dans le cadre de la
feuille de route mais je vais me
concentrer sur la principale retenue
comme un des temps fort des politiques
gouvernementales dans l'anticipation des
pénuries de médicaments la question des
stocks
nous avons fixé une obligation de
constitution d'un stock de sécurité
permanent de deux mois pour tous les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeurs et d'une semaine pour les autres
médicaments avec possibilité de contrôle
et donc de sanction
ce décret 10 stock a été arraché je peux
vous le dire de haute lutte auprès de
l'Europe et j'espère aujourd'hui que ce
dispositif sera repris à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne à la hauteur des
critères français de manière à avoir un
poids plus fort vis-à-vis des
laboratoires et traduire une vision
partagée de l'accès aux médicaments pour
les patients européens j'étais
rapporteur général j'étais intervenu
pour que ces stocks soient constitués à
l'échelle du territoire européen je vais
pas vous dire de bêtises parce qu'on est
sous serment il me semble que
l'unanimité n'était pas loin si tentait
qu'elle n'était pas au rendez-vous
c'était un combat parlementaire que
j'avais mené pour être tout à fait
exhaustif après avoir été amené à
repousser des amendements je crois lors
du PLFSS précédent parce que c'était des
amendements qui étaient inspirés
d'association qui s'étaient mobilisés et
que je salue parce qu'elles ont été
déterminantes la rédaction ne permettait
pas d'être conforme aux droits européens
je m'étais engagé à revenir l'année
d'après avec une disposition cette
fois-ci conforme c'était une bataille
non pas parlementaire parce que je crois
qu'il y avait quand même consensus même
si certains députés trouvaient que on
aurait pu aller plus loin que cela mais
ça a été aussi une bataille pour prendre
le décret pour le faire accepter au
niveau de la Commission européenne je
vous dis ça parce que c'est aussi une
manière pardon d'illustrer mon
application sur le sujet et ma vigilance
a anticipé ces pénuries alors que je
n'étais pas encore Ministre en charge la
seconde mesure d'ampleur a été une
refonte de l'ensemble de la procédure
des plantes gestion des pénuries par la
NSM afin de renforcer nos capacités
d'adaptation par ailleurs dans cette
bataille de l'anticipation vous le savez
l'accès à l'information est cruciale
aussi le déploiement du logiciel des
perructures par l'Ordre des pharmaciens
je salue et remercie à participer
pleinement à cet effort développer des
2013 ce logiciel est maintenant utilisé
dans la quasi-totalité des officines en
France
mon objectif comme ministre était clair
que les Français soient les premiers à
avoir accès aux médicaments lorsqu'il y
avait des innovations et qu'ils étaient
et qu'il soit les derniers à en manquer
la deuxième partie de mon propos est
naturellement orientée autour de la
crise covid-19 car vous le savez à la
bousculé le déploiement de notre feuille
de route en particulier et la planète
entière en général en effet la crise a
eu deux effets sur les pénuries des
médicaments un effet micro la feuille de
route était un cadre qu'il fallait
dépasser et un effet macro la mise à
l'arrêt d'une partie de la planète
allait avoir un effet certain sur la
production mondiale de médicaments
lorsque je me réfère à l'effet des
micros je veux bien évidemment éviter
tout malentendu la crise n'a pas eu pour
conséquence de rendre la feuille de
route obsolète bien au contraire la
crise a accéléré son déploiement et ses
ambitions dans le même temps il a fallu
s'en dégager parfois pour mener des
actions complémentaires face à des
pénuries mondiales et face à une
succession d'événements divers et variés
à l'instar de la pénurie de carton qui
de prime abord n'est pas un événement de
nature à créer une pénurie de
médicaments et pourtant
face à cette situation inédite nous
avons fait preuve d'innovation il le
fallait je pense ici à la mobilisation
d'un réseau de pharmaciens hospitalier
pour produire des médicaments grâce
notamment à la pharmacie de l'AP-HP qui
s'appelle l'ajeps que je tiens à
remercier très solennellement de votre
commission d'enquête en urgence nous
avons produit en France du 6
attracturium qui était alors en rupture
de stock un scalopp a été réalisé avec
un sous-traitant privé pour les besoins
des patients sur le territoire repris
dans la LFSS 2022 ce dispositif vise à
favoriser la production de médicaments
en cas de situation critique par les
femmes par les pharmacies à usage
intérieur des établissements de santé et
les établissements pharmaceutiques
publics habilités en faisant appel à des
établissements privés sous-traitants il
pourra être mobilisable en cas de
rupture ou de crise sanitaire nos
actions de crise ont été traduites dans
la loi c'est une excellente nouvelle
dont il faut se féliciter
par ailleurs qui dit crise dit aussi
reprise la France a accompagné cet élan
ainsi dans le cadre de France relance le
ministère de la Santé a travaillé en
étroite collaboration avec la Direction
Générale des Entreprises la DGE depuis
2020 à la mise en place de dispositifs
visant à re-développer les productions
en France pour réduire la dépendance
extra-européenne 150 projets ont été
soutenus 1,3 milliards d'euros
d'investissements industriels 650
millions d'aides d'État dédiés être
d'État qui s'élève à 1,5 milliards
d'euros dans le cadre du dispositif
France 2030 grâce au dérogations
européennes au titre des piecques et
pardonner un instant pour chevinisme
mais nous sommes fiers en Isère de nous
préparer à réaccueillir la production de
paracétamol suite à l'engagement du
président de la République en juin 2020
dans le cadre de France relance surtout
et ce constat sera la parfaite
transition vers mon troisième point la
crise a définitivement confirmée que la
politique du médicament devait se penser
et être traduite au niveau européen pour
qu'elle soit pleinement efficace
je reviens par là à la dernière partie
de mon propos donc autour de piste de
réflexion d'abord la solution est
européenne je serai sentencieux à ce
sujet il faut surtout pas se tromper de
combat la solution ne peut être que
européenne pourquoi parce que les
industriels ne produisent pas qu'en
France parce que la production de
médicaments n'est pas soumise au même
aléas au même ordre et critères d'un
pays à un autre comme nous avons mené la
bataille du vaccin en européen nous
devons mener celle de
l'approvisionnement de médicaments à
cette même échelle si la France venait à
poser un cadre d'obligation nationale
bien trop strict vis-à-vis de ses
voisins nous prendrions le risque d'une
perte de compétitivité qui nous
fragiliserait dans l'accès aux
médicaments c'est d'ailleurs le sens de
l'engagement pris par les deux ministres
messieurs Braun et Lescure au service
d'une nouvelle stratégie en matière de
prévention et de gestion des pénuries
ensuite il faut viser la sobriété dans
la consommation des médicaments il faut
garder à l'esprit que la France fait
partie des pays en Europe et dans le
monde où la consommation de médicaments
et la plus forte il me semble qu'une des
solutions se trouve dans la réduction de
notre consommation de médicaments à
travers plusieurs leviers d'abord la
dispensation à l'unité permise par la
loi anti-gaspillage pour une économie
circulaire je salue d'ailleurs
l'engagement c'était brune Poirson qui
était secrétaire d'État à la transition
écologique à l'époque en faveur de ce
dispositif qui est hélas aujourd'hui
trop peu employé je m'étais d'ailleurs
mobilisé comme député pour les
antibiotiques parce que les
antibiotiques c'était quelque chose qui
s'y prêtait peut-être davantage que des
médicaments qui peuvent être parfois
conditionnés en des boîtes plus
importantes pour des gens qui sont
atteints de maladies chroniques des
expérimentations ont été conduites mais
on voit que de la théorie à l'acte c'est
assez compliqué on vous parlera de la
sérialisation de la sécurisation etc qui
fait que cette idée excellente pour
mémoire je crois que c'était l'idée la
plus souvent remonter dans le cadre de
la grande marche de la campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 et que le
passage la réalisation en pratique ce
Heart a beaucoup de contraintes
notamment normatives ensuite
l'augmentation de la maîtrise
médicalisée est un autre levier pour
cela il faut accompagner un changement
de culture toute consultation médicale
ne doit pas nécessairement être conclu
par les prescriptions d'un médicament
enfin il faut renforcer notre vigilance
sur la prescription à tout va
d'antibiotiques ça demeure une priorité
notamment en renforçant notre capacité
et notre recours à des tests permettant
de définir tout simplement si une
infection est virale ou bactérienne on a
développé les trodes tests rapides en
pharmacie il faut sans doute aller plus
loin dans la capacité des Français être
capable de voir par eux-mêmes s'il
relève d'une ordonnance d'antibiotiques
ou non je ferai peut-être plaisir à
Madame larapeur Laurence Cohen en citant
hors de mon texte je crois que c'était
ivan Ilitch qui avait écrit un ouvrage
il y a de cela 50 ans qui s'appelle
Nemesis médical et qui racontait par le
menu comment à force d'expliquer aux
gens que la santé ne leur appartenait
plus enfin l'évaluation de leur santé de
leur appartenait plus mais appartenait à
des experts on les avait éloignés d'un
certain nombre de connaissances pourtant
fondamentales qui doivent permettre à
des citoyens français d'être capable de
davantage s'autonomiser dans la gestion
d'un certain nombre de maladies dites
courantes je ferme la parenthèse il va
nieditch
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous avez au
dictionnaire la délégué j'ai pu c'est
une délégué ministérielle à
l'antibio-résistance qui fait un travail
formidable moi que je recevais tous les
trois mois comme ministres dans mon
bureau et qui a obtenu déjà des
résultats importants en matière de
réduction de prescription d'antibiotique
ainsi il s'agit que les médecins
prescrivent moins que les pharmaciens
délivre moins et que les Français
consomment mieux de la sobriété en santé
en somme il s'agit pas d'une punition
s'agit pas d'un aveu de faiblesse au
contraire on doit faire évoluer nos
usages pour viser juste consommation ni
trop ni trop peu des médicaments dans
notre pays
troisièmement pas de médicaments sans
industrie son industrie verte évidemment
cette question de l'approvisionnement
médicament n'est pas la seule
prérogative des ministres de la santé
elle est éminemment industrielle et
pardonnez-moi d'enfoncer des portes
ouvertes mais je pense qu'elle est
cruciale en effet je faisais référence à
l'impact environnemental de cette
industrie en introduction nous parlons
souvent de réimplantation dans nos
territoires de notre production de
relocalisation d'usine qui aujourd'hui
pour la plupart situé sur le continent
asiatique mais nous le savons la
situation n'est pas aussi évidente ou
simple que cela
la question du futur du médicament est
donc intimement liée à celle du
verdissement de notre industrie et ce
d'autant que les pays actuellement
producteurs de matières premières sont
eux aussi en train d'opérer des
changements de paradigme au regard de
l'urgence écologique en 30 ans la
production de 80% des principes actifs a
été délocalisé en Asie 80% des principes
actifs nécessaires à fabriquer des
médicaments y compris ceux d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur pour la population
mondiale sont concentrées dans quelques
pays d'Asie quand sera-t-il lorsque ces
pays ne voudront plus produire ces
principes actifs ou lorsque des tensions
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver à
l'avenir on le souhaite pas les tensions
géopolitiques pourraient conduire à des
pressions sur ces chaînes de délivrance
des principes actifs au reste du monde
je
m'interroge avec vous c'est 30 ans de
politique de désindustrialisation dans
le monde occidental ce sont accompagnés
d'une prise de risque que j'estime
majeure madame la Présidente vous
parliez tout à l'heure des masques
j'en ferai l'analogie un moment donné il
a été considéré que la production de
masques délocalisée en Asie en
l'occurrence en Chine et dans une seule
quasiment province chinoise était de
nature à réduire les coûts et permettre
d'alimenter toute la planète en masque
dont acte enfin avec le recul on peut
quand même se dire que c'est bien de
garder un peu de souveraineté le mot
n'est pas moche au contraire et vous
savez qui tient à coeur du président de
la République
quatrièmement quel juste prix pour le
médicament j'ai pas eu l'idée la
question j'en terminerai par là sans
pour autant vouloir réduire ce qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui à une question
pécuniaire mais force est de constater
que la question du prix du médicament
c'est un corollaire de sa pénurie
j'assume le formuler cette interrogation
devant votre commission d'enquête là
vous n'avons nous pas maintenu le prix
des médicaments trop bas trop longtemps
la mission annoncée par la première
ministre Elisabeth borne sur la fixation
du prix du médicament rendra bientôt ses
conclusions il nous faudra
collectivement y être à l'écoute car il
me semble qu'une partie de l'enjeu une
partie de l'enjeu réside ici nos
concitoyens le constatent aujourd'hui
tout augmente du beurre en passant par
la baguette ou le steak congelé tout
augmente sauf le médicament et ce alors
que le prix de l'électricité le cours
mondial des matières premières eux ont
grimpé en flèche notamment suite au long
confinement de la Chine et l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie lorsque les prix
sont administrés c'est l'industriel qui
absorbe le choc et cette réflexion que
je vous livre n'est en rien une
intervention au soutien au laboratoire
je crois que mon passé parlementaire et
comme isolé mes cartes de tourisme de ce
point de vue là mais c'est
l'anticipation d'un possible l'effet
d'éviction qui viendrait renforcer les
pénuries en France l'enjeu
d'attractivité de notre pays reste
primordial car il n'est pas exclu et
c'est un euphémisme
que les laboratoires effectuent leur
choix en fonction des conditions
économiques d'un marché en dépit de tout
évaluation des besoins réels à contrario
le prix des médicaments innovants
atteint lui des sommets certaines
thérapies dépassent les 2 millions
d'euros je ne rentrerai pas dans ces
considérations éthiques de construction
du prix du thérapie de l'innovation et
donc de celui d'une vie le Conseil
consultatif national d'éthique a
brillamment abordé le sujet en soulevant
les questions les dilemmes et la nature
des arbitrages dans un avis de grande
sagesse c'est la vie 101 intitulé santé
éthique et argent qui se terminent ainsi
par ses mots inspirants la question
éthique posée par l'examen de la
dimension économique du soin explorent
la tension entre l'autonomie et la
solidarité entre la liberté individuelle
et le bien public cette tension ne peut
recevoir de réponse que dans la
recherche d'équité c'est-à-dire dans la
justice
c'est la même recherche d'équilibre
entre des réalités et des ambitions
chacune légitime chacune bienvenue qui
doit guider l'action publique dans
l'identification des solutions afin de
continuer à anticiper et à mieux
anticiper les pénuries nationales et
européennes que nous connaissons et
celles à venir je vous remercie de votre
attention je suis évidemment disponible
pour vos questions
merci beaucoup pour ces longs profonds
liminaires qui ont abordé tous les
sujets je vais directement passer la
parole à Madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur pour une première salle de
questions merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre propos liminaire donc je vais
un peu suivre d'ailleurs la trame de
votre propos puisque vous êtes parti à
juste titre de la feuille de route de
2019 à 2022
et effectivement cette feuille de route
avait fait de la transparence et de
l'exhaustivité de l'information sur les
ruptures d'approvisionnement un des axes
majeurs de la politique du gouvernement
vous l'avez d'ailleurs rappelé mais
cette ambition apparaît
assez inachevée la plupart des personnes
que nous avons auditionné regrettent en
fait on regrettait devant notre
commission d'enquête un manque
d'informations et je pense plus
particulièrement au médecin un décalage
entre l'information que peuvent avoir
les pharmaciens et d'ailleurs vous avez
parlé du logiciel des perructures et les
médecins nous ont dit qu'en fait ils
étaient informés alertés par les par les
pharmaciens mais que eux disposaient de
peu d'informations en tout cas j'allais
dire pas comme en étant en première
ligne alors quels sont à votre avis les
points de blocage pourquoi est-ce que il
en est ainsi est-ce qu'il y a pas des
mesures simples et rapides à apprendre
pour modifier cet état cet état de fait
vous parlez en deuxième deuxième élément
de de la crise du covid qui a accéléré
l'ambition de la feuille de route et a
juste titre je partage vous rendez
hommage au réseau hospitalier et à lapse
et justement nous avons auditionné la
geppe ce qui a fait comme vous l'avez
dit un travail absolument remarquable
pendant la période notamment de la crise
et quand nous l'avons nous avons
interrogé donc la GEPS en fait qu'ils
ont pu faire et produire pendant la
crise ils ne peuvent pas leur faire hors
de période de crise car en fait les
règlements ne le permettent pas et en
plus vous le savez très bien monsieur le
ministre la GEF n'a pas vocation d'être
en concurrence il y a un certain nombre
d'articles que je vous rappellerai pas
mais que vous connaissez qui qui le
stipule et troisième élément de blocage
si je puis dire que actuellement ils ont
un effectif qui est assez assez faible
au vu des missions qu'ils ont c'est à
peu près 120
ETP et là ils vont se séparer de 40 à 50
TP ce qui va les priver de possibilités
de production etc or c'est dommage c'est
un outil qui peut être extrêmement
intéressant et est-ce que on ne pourrait
pas justement s'appuyer sur la GEPS en
leur donnant les moyens pour avoir
sur des produits pas seulement les
produits qui sont
médicalement d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur mais sur une liste vraiment
critique est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
avoir justement quand je dis critique ça
veut dire restreinte si vous voulez et
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas envisager
contenu de ces pénuries et vous nous
l'avez rappelé qui malheureusement
peuvent encore augmenter ou en tout cas
s'étendre à d'autres à d'autres produits
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas envisager pour
cette cinquantaine de produits critiques
d'avoir une production publique qui nous
permettrait de retrouver notre
souveraineté ça c'était un deuxième
deuxième question là la troisième
question c'est concernant la le manque
de gouvernance de l'ensemble du système
qui a souvent été mis en avant et
d'ailleurs dans votre ouvrage je vous
cite vous dites il y a une nuit de sigle
qui traduit la complexité et la densité
des agences et structures françaises
dans le champ de la santé alors à la
lumière de vos deux années au ministère
de la Santé est-ce qu'il vous paraît que
une réforme de la gouvernance est
souhaitable vous voyez je vous cite
l'autre question que je veux vous poser
c'est dans la politique on a vu que le
médicament en fait était une variable
d'ajustement au niveau de l'onde hélas
et que autrement dit les contraintes
budgétaires qui sont imposées au secteur
sont extrêmement fortes et elles ne sont
pas compatibles avec une sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement en médicaments
vous savez ma position par rapport à la
dame donc c'est pas de ça donc je me
débattre mais je veux regretter et avoir
votre votre point de vue là dessus sur
le fait que dans cette enveloppe on dame
et bien le médicament est vraiment le
parent pauvre j'ai dit la variable
d'ajustement
mon autre question c'est que vous avez
souligné la politique de relocalisation
de la production de certains principes
actifs essentiels et effectivement vous
êtes l'élu d'un département qui est
fortement marquée par par l'industrie
chimique et nous avons pu avec madame la
Présidente aller visiter le site de
l'usine future du paracétamol que ces 15
relocalisent et d'ailleurs nous avons
visité une zone qui regroupe vous le
savez plusieurs sites ce vaisseau c'est
une plateforme qui est extrêmement
intéressante qui fédère vraiment
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses qui leur
permettent d'avoir une production
sécurisée on va dire donc comment la
France peut encore disons favoriser de
telles relocalisation parce que c'est
une expérience qui est intéressante
c'est bien mais en même temps
il faut peut-être multiplier les choses
mon propos ne vous méprenez pas c'est
pas de dire qu'il faut tout relocaliser
en France ce serait complètement stupide
je pense qu'il faut une coordination et
vous l'avez souligné au niveau européen
et qu'il faut relocaliser au niveau
européen dans une parfaite harmonie
entre les différents les différents pays
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2022 que vous avez
porté il y avait
prévu d'ajouter un nouveau critère de
tarification du médicament tenant à
l'implantation industrielle justement
c'est pour ça que je fais les liens avec
ces cases etc le sept que nous avons
auditionné nous indiquer que son
utilisation pourrait se limiter aux
médicaments innovants et
de mon point de vue si on ne vise pas
prioritairement les médicaments matures
qui représentent l'essentiel des
pénuries est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
monsieur le ministre que nous manquons
la cible en tout cas que cette mesure va
manquer sa cible et qu'il faudrait ne
pas se limiter à seulement ces
médicaments enfin ma dernière question
c'est concernant les prix des des
médicaments
il nous est apparu en tout cas dans les
dans les dans toutes les auditions que
nous avons pu avoir qui ressortaient en
fait on va dire quatre d'abord le besoin
de transparence de ces prix parce que
nous avons été extrêmement au départ
surprise et surpris mais du fait que
personne n'était bien au fait de ce que
faisait le sexe et qu'est-ce qui le CEPS
pardon et ce que faisait qu'est-ce qui
constituait le prix qu'elles étaient les
critères etc mais ce qui ressort c'est
en fait d'avoir une vraie transparence
sur le prix et que soit vraiment dans
cette transparence pris en compte le
coût de production réelle
le respect des normes environnementales
et le respect aussi des conditions de
travail donc des normes on va dire
sociales pour aller vite parce que si
les il y a eu des localisations en Chine
et en Asie là encore vous l'avez
souligné c'était par rapport
aux normes environnementales qui étaient
vraiment moins exigeant je veux dire et
puis y compris les conditions salariales
etc donc deuxième le respect le service
évidemment médical rendu je vois
peut-être dû lui dire en premier c'est
pas hiérarchiser et enfin le bénéfice
normal entre guillemets normal ou
éthique ou reconnu par tous évidemment
pour produire ce prix et si on a cette
transparence au niveau du prix du du
médicament il y aura quand même une vue
d'ensemble qui permettra à chacun et à
chacune d'avoir un positionnement et y
compris d'ailleurs de redonner confiance
il me semble aux patientes et aux
patient s voilà les questions qui me
viennent à l'esprit après vous avoir
entendu et je vous remercie d'avance de
vos réponses
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
c'est noté cette question madame la
rapporteur d'abord sur le décalage
d'information entre les médecins et le
pharmacien sur les ruptures alors
aujourd'hui les ruptures sont tout
inscrites sur le site de l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut aller
chercher l'information et on a eu
effectivement le des retours comme quoi
c'était pas très simple de s'y connecter
et donc l'idée est peut-être
effectivement de revoir cela je crois
qu'il y a une mission qui est en cours
en tout cas un travail qui est en cours
pour vendre des choses plus
intelligibles après si je prends ma
casquette de médecin je recevais de
temps en temps des mails sur ma boîte
hospitalière m'informant que des
médicaments qui étaient relatifs à ma
discipline allait être en pénurie mais
parfois c'est vrai que je prescrivais
des médicaments à des patients qui me
rappelaient en me disant c'est sympa
docteur mais enfin personne n'en a donc
c'est assez pénible et je sais et là je
me mets à la place du médecin on ne
comprend pas pourquoi est-ce que tel
médicament n'est plus disponible alors
que c'est un médicament qu'on a
l'habitude d'utiliser c'est un peu
rageant donc il faut sans doute rendre
l'information plus intelligible je
prends votre point en tout cas je le
transmets
deuxième question sur la loi prévoit que
la production oui vous parler de la GEPS
sur la dans les faits il y a un
texte qui est en préparation
là-dessus
il y a une nouvelle feuille de route en
réalité qui est en préparation elle
devra tirer les conclusions de ce qui
s'est passé pendant la crise moi je suis
sensible je trouve pertinente si vous
permettez les caractériser les pistes
que vous dessinez au ministre de la
Santé de de dans décider
au quotidien c'est pas le rôle de la
c'est évidemment mais c'est parce que
vous dites de produire des médicaments
d'usage courant pour toute la population
parce que là il sait pas c'est pas 120
ou plus ou moins 40 qu'il faudrait c'est
évidemment sans ou 200 fois plus de
salariés vous faites allusion à ce qui
pourrait ressembler à l'idée du pôle
public du médicament à travers votre de
votre question
plus restreint pour la production
publique en tout cas de médicaments
faut pas écarter cette possibilité j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de la crise avec le
sisa tractium qui a montré que c'était
possible j'ai connaissance du fait qu'il
y a des tensions autour de
l'amoxicilline pendant les que pour les
tensions autour de la boxicilline il y a
eu des préparations magistrats et
hospitalières qui ont été largement
utilisés à nouveau là c'est au ministre
de ce prononcer sur sur ces questions
réforme de la gouvernance en santé alors
là vous ouvrez quelque chose qui me
semble-t-il beaucoup plus large que que
la question médicament qui nous
occupe on pourrait parler de savoir si
le parachèvement de la loi de rosier le
bachot vous avez auditionné passe ou non
par la création d'une Agence nationale
etc voilà c'est là on est dans quelque
chose qui qui est extrêmement grand mais
je pense qu'on peut faire effectivement
une simplification du paysage est
différente agences sanitaires mais c'est
pas mon rôle que de que de que dire que
de dire laquelle
le médicament pour la régulation de la
dame je l'ai dit en introduction il y a
une mission qui est en cours donnée
lancée par la première ministre les
conclusions environ sûrement une
réflexion macroéconomique sur la
régulation des produits de santé après
fort de mes quelques années au Parlement
et de mes quelques années comme
rapporteur général et je vois les
sénateurs mignons qui dira pas l'inverse
même si au Sénat peut-être que le débat
était moins farouche mais le la partie
médicament de la dame même la sénatrice
m'a rapporteur à l'Assemblée nationale
était généralement assez bipartisanes
c'était le moment où il y avait une
partie de l'hémicycle je dirais laquelle
qui trouvait qu'on en donnait trop et
une partie des mystiques qui trouvait
qu'on en donnait pas assez donc je ferai
pas ici de politique mais c'est
intéressant et c'est bien peut-être
effectivement de d'acter le fait que les
médicaments ont un prix et que c'est un
prix pour la nation aussi mais que c'est
important parce que c'est quand on faut
pas attendre d'en manquer pour s'en
rendre compte
vous appelez à plus de relocalisation
pardon
mais je sais mais je parle de mon
expérience personnelle je n'ai pas
d'expérience je n'ai pas encore eu la
chance d'être sénateur si jamais ça
arrivait un jour je me ferais ma propre
idée
et je sais que le Sénat est capable
d'avoir des
affranchir des clivages partisans que la
traditionnel sur la relocalisation vous
donnez le chiffre qui je crois est
factuel de plus d'un bilan qui est de
plus de sang en deux ans c'est à dire
qu'il y a eu 200 usines de plus qui ont
ouvertes qui a eu d'usine qui ont fermé
en deux ans dans notre pays je parle pas
à la queue du médicament mais ce qui a
déjà contraste avec des années pour ne
pas dire des décennies de
désindustrialisation et Marx il était
besoin de le marquer
que la volonté du Président de la
République de retrouver la souveraineté
française européenne en matière
productive et industrielle commence à
porter ses fruits et donc parmi ses
usines il y a des usines qui seront
amenées à fabriquer des médicaments je
voulais dire mon sens c'est plutôt un
sujet européen qu'un sujet français il
faut qu'on puisse se répartir et pour ça
qu'il faut qu'il y a une coopération une
coordonnation coordination européenne
assez assez précoce vous parlez de
mettre en place un critère de production
en France dans le prix de tous les
médicaments alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
l'avait fait pour les médicaments
innovants je sais plus si le texte se
limitait au sol médicament innovant ou
non
LFSS 2022 dont vous parlez je peux pas
dans mes fonctions actuelles tirer le
bilan la mission sur la régulation s'y
intéresse chers unique cet article c'est
déjà une avancée parce que nombreux sont
celles et ceux qui demandaient de
prendre en compte la dimension
industrielle dans la fixation du prix et
on est allé on a adopté quelque chose
qui était qui est sans doute plus plus
précis plus précis que cela et sur le
besoin de transparence dans les prix
alors il y a la notion de secret des
affaires et de secret de l'industriel
qui fait que il y a des choses dont nous
n'avons pas à connaître publiquement ça
je crois que il y a eu plusieurs fois ce
débat dans les différents hémicycles et
à chaque fois c'était cet argument mais
qui me paraît tout à fait valable
il y a eu beaucoup de grands projets de
grands soirs de la grande réforme de
laboration de la manière de trouver le
prix d'un médicament je crois qu'il y
avait même littr c'était l'index
thérapeutique relatif qui devait
permettre de fusionner le SMS et la SMR
tous ces signes qu'on adore les
politiques publiques et en santé en
particulier pour avoir un espèce
d'indicateur composite qui tiendrait
compte de l'ensemble des coûts de
production de transport d'innovation et
en fait ça n'a jamais vraiment vu le
jour parce qu'à chaque fois ça se
heurter à la complexité d'un marché
mondialisé mais sans doute qu'on peut
faire mieux dans la façon de déterminer
le prix d'un médicament voilà pour cette
audition d'Olivier Vérand devant la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur la
pénurie de médicaments une commission
d'enquête qui a également entendu Xavier
Bertrand actuel président de la Région
Hauts-de-France et ancien ministre de la
Santé sous Nicolas Sarkozy je vous
laisse écouter son audition
j'ai donc assumé cette fonction à deux
reprises c'est très belle fonction à
deux reprises peut-être en y ajoutant
également la partie de fin mars 2004
jusqu'à juin 2005 où j'étais sur
l'autorité de Philippe bouste Blazy en
charge de l'Assurance maladie non pas en
charge directement de la politique de
santé ou de la politique du médicament
mais sur l'un des éléments concernant
notamment le prix d'un certain nombre de
produits de produits de santé vous
l'avez vous même souligné j'y reviendrai
à l'occasion des questions il est vrai
que en 2011 il y a à la fois le plan
d'action qui est présenté en septembre
2011 et la loi médicament qui a été
adoptée fin décembre 2011 qui ont permis
de changer un certain nombre de choses
concernant justement la disponibilité
des produits de santé la disponibilité
des médicaments mais si j'en viens à ce
qui était la grille de lecture à
l'époque et ce qui est aujourd'hui la
grille de lecture que je me permettrai
de présenter devant de votre commission
d'enquête ça tient trois choses c'est
l'absolu nécessité dans le domaine de la
santé de l'anticipation
nous avons une question clé aujourd'hui
de prix
et nous avons aussi une remise en
question à mon sens de ce que nous
mettons derrière le mot souveraineté
concernant la disponibilité des produits
de santé au-delà même de la question du
prix les pénuries parce que c'est le
réellement je ne comprends absolument
pas pourquoi il y a aujourd'hui une
fausse pudeur gouvernementale à nier la
réalité des faits c'est pas un problème
de tension dans les stocks
d'une insulte professionnelle de santé
aux patient de dire que c'est une
tension des stocks c'est une pénurie et
j'aurais bien aimé qu'au-delà des
différentes déclarations du ministre en
charge de la santé qui nous dit tous les
15 jours qui a pas de pénurie que les
problèmes vont se régler j'aurais bien
aimé la voir avec quoi voilà encore deux
semaines dans une pharmacie quand vous
avez besoin d'avoir des médicaments pour
vos enfants c'est sur les médicaments
pédiatriques que le scandale est le plus
patant de bien voir que c'était pas un
problème de tension c'est un problème
tout simplement de pénurie donc un
problème d'anticipation problème de prix
et ensuite une nouvelle définition de ce
que nous mettons derrière le terme de
souveraineté parce que c'est pénuries
vont être amenées à se reproduire
régulièrement et elles vont devenir de
plus en plus vives dans les années qui
viennent on l'a tout simplement le
propos liminaire que je voulais avoir
très bien
c'est parfait merci beaucoup je passe la
parole à Laurence Cohen rapporteur pour
une première série de questions
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
propos extrêmement court mais en même
temps très synthétique et qui met
vraiment les projecteurs sur les
problèmes réels tels que tel qu'ils se
présente alors effectivement
vous avez vous avez raison de de
souligner que là nous sommes face à des
pénuries et malheureusement
ces pénuries ne font que se multiplier
c'est-à-dire au fur et à mesure il y a
de plus en plus de médicaments qui sont
touchés et les médicaments qui ont été
particulièrement touchés c'est
effectivement les médicaments à usage
pédiatrique qui ont été très touchés moi
j'aimerais donc que vous puissiez
approfondir un certain nombre d'éléments
quand en 2011 vous avez donc annoncé un
plan d'action pour justement lutter
contre les ruptures de stock de
médicaments la situation n'était pas la
même en 2011 qu'elle est évidemment
aujourd'hui mais je voudrais savoir
comment les acteurs de la chaîne du
médicament avait-il réagi à ses
propositions et avec le recul que vous
pouvez avoir aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez que ces mesures
étaient suffisantes et comment
aujourd'hui on peut modifier les choses
pour dépasser les problèmes que nous
vivons ça c'est ma première ma première
question ma deuxième question concerne
effectivement ce qui a souligné la
présidente concernant votre action quant
à la création de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament
est-ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui qu'il
est pertinent de confier à cette agence
la surveillance et la gestion des des
ruptures de stock de médicaments et
est-ce que vous pensez également que
cette agence dispose de moyens
financiers humains suffisants ce qu'on a
pu constater lors de des auditions des
différentes agences c'est leur demande
de plus en plus de responsabilités de
plus en plus de missions mais j'allais
dire en fait à moyen constance qui ce
qui est quand même un peu plus compliqué
la troisième la troisième question là
encore c'est que c'est venu très
fortement dans les différentes auditions
si le problème de gouvernance et de
pilotage de l'ensemble de la politique
du médicament
de manière familière où il y a un
certain nombre d'auditionnés qui nous
ont dit qu'en fait ils se demandaient
s'il y avait un pilote dans l'avion pour
le dire de manière familière donc
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait mettre justement en
oeuvre pour remédier à ce problème
ma quatrième question ça concerne
l'engagement du du gouvernement
aujourd'hui de relocaliser les
médicaments et les principes actifs
effectivement c'est une politique qui
date depuis 30 ans où il y a eu une des
délocalisations extrêmement importantes
délocalisations d'ailleurs qui était
voulu parce que
il semblait beaucoup plus rentable
d'installer les industries en Asie
notamment où en Inde avec une exigence
des critères environnementaux et sociaux
moindres aujourd'hui on revient sur
cette sur cette sur ces données et sur
cette politique plus exactement et on
parle de relocalisation relocalisation
il faut il faut raisons garder on va pas
relocaliser en France toutes les
médicaments il faut qu'il y ait une
harmonisation en bonne int pour le moins
avec avec
l'Europe et je voudrais savoir parce que
vous avez votre expérience de ministre
notamment mais vous êtes vous êtes élu
d'une région irresponsable d'une région
industrielle et dans laquelle il y a
plusieurs sites de fabrication
très importants et je pense à Sanofi
mais il y a d'autres je vais pas toutes
les citer parce qu'elles sont elles sont
nombreuses donc à votre avis comment
est-ce qu'il faut procéder pour qu'il y
ait de réels relocalisation est-ce que
finalement
il ne faut pas prendre en compte le fait
que à partir du moment où il y a une
relocalisation en France et en Europe et
bien il faut prendre en compte donc
cette relocalisation y compris dans le
prix du médicament parce que sinon on va
entraîner une concurrence qui va pas
être équitable si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi et
est-ce que vous pensez parce que là
encore quand j'ai parlé de critères
environnementaux c'est que tout le monde
se dit aujourd'hui ou beaucoup la
majorité se disent aujourd'hui oui il
faut relocaliser mais en même temps si
on a délocalisé l'industrie chimique
c'est qu'elle était polluante donc
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est prêt
quand je dis on est prêt c'est
collectivement parce qu'un élu qui dit
voilà je vais rapatrier dans ma région
il peut aussi avoir une levée de
bouclier en disant mais pas pas ici pas
chez nous donc est-ce qu'on est en
mesure aujourd'hui de maîtriser
l'empreinte environnementale de de ces
relocalisations
et puis je voudrais vous interroger de
manière toujours dans le même ordre
d'idées de manière peut-être un peu plus
précise parce que la semaine dernière
nous avons rencontré le PDG du groupe
Atlantis qui a indiqué donc la
liquidation judiciaire de l'usine
syntaxime de Calais et
il a il a il a signifié qu'il pour lui
il était impossible de relocaliser en
France la production de molécules à très
gros volume et à faible valeur ajoutée
donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez de de ce
constat et comment dans ce cas sécuriser
l'approvisionnement de la France et de
l'Europe en médicament mature qui sont
fréquemment utilisés par par les
Français enfin ma toute dernière
question c'est peut-être encore plus
précisément sur le prix j'ai donné un
indice si je puis dire en disant qu'il
fallait prendre en compte la
relocalisation en France et et en Europe
mais au cours de nos de nos auditions la
question du prix est revenue fortement
je ne veux pas simplifier la donne comme
aucun d'ailleurs de mes collègues autour
de cette table les pénuries c'est
multifactoriels et il y a pas qu'une
solution ça serait ça serait trop facile
mais par rapport à ce à ce prix vous
avez déclaré me semble-t-il assez
récemment que il fallait payer les
médicaments plus chers qu'aujourd'hui je
pense que vous faisiez allusion
évidemment enfin aux médicaments matures
mais je veux pas transformer vos propos
mais ça me semble évident mais on a
constaté que dans d'autres pays où les
prix des médicaments est beaucoup plus
onéreux je pense notamment à la Suisse
il souffrait des mêmes pénuries et
notamment au niveau des au niveau des
antibiotiques donc on voit bien là que
les choses ne sont pas si simple que ça
et du coup je fais un lien avec l'ONDAM
qui est consacrée aux médicaments et qui
sert quand même de variables
d'ajustement aux réductions de budget de
la santé d'une manière générale et que
peut-être là on est allé aussi trop loin
dans la faiblesse de cette de cette
enveloppe en jouant jouer n'est pas le
mot exact mais
en faisant un espèce d'équilibre entre
les produits innovants dont les prix
s'envolent et les produits matures dans
les prix sont bas voilà les six
questions que je voulais vous poser
monsieur le ministre vous voyez que du
coup je balaye beaucoup de points
on vous remercie infiniment de vos
propos c'est exactement
tout à l'heure vous permettez de les
prendre à l'envers de façon à ce que la
mémoire soit plus fraîche sur la
question de lambda oui vous avez raison
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai indiqué
à l'un de son suivi pardon le sénateur
Milon s'en souvient certainement lors de
l'examen du dernier PLFSS qui précédait
l'élection présidentielle et d'ailleurs
je vais reprendre exactement j'ai pas
retrouvé les termes exact de ma
déclaration mais les termes de utilisés
par Nora Berra qui était ma secrétaire
d'État chargée de la Santé qui est une
représentait aux banc de l'Assemblée
nationale lors de l'examen du PLFSS 2012
le 27 octobre 2011 j'ai pas retrouvé les
minutes du Sénat disait la chose
suivante mon nom
c'est mon temps
d'économie demandait aux médicaments ces
montants doivent rester compatibles avec
le développement d'une industrie à force
d'investissement il s'agit d'un enjeu
essentiel toute démarche à un début mais
aussi une fin
des prélèvements d'un montant total de
1,26 milliards d'euros sont déjà assez
substantielles car il faut laisser
l'industrie pharmaceutique l'opportunité
d'investir dans les produits de santé
qui seront utiles à la prise en charge
des patients à l'avenir de façon moins
protocolaire j'ai toujours eu coutume de
dire que j'avais demandé beaucoup
d'efforts à l'industrie du médicament
beaucoup parce que j'ai été en charge à
partir de 2004 une réforme de
l'assurance maladie qui visait à
sauvegarder notre système de santé
l'assurance maladie mais j'avais indiqué
qu'on était certainement allé jusqu'à
l'os et que nous ne pouvions pas
demander des forces supplémentaires dans
les 10 ans qui sont écoulés des efforts
supplémentaires ont été demandés et
après on s'étonne du résultat je le dis
très clairement ici à la tribune du
Sénat
dans un PLFSS mémorable où il avait été
question le sénateur Milan s'en souvient
d'autres débats opticiens optométristes
et autres mais on était sur cette
question là à l'époque j'avais demandé
beaucoup d'efforts et j'ai dit on ne
pourra pas continuer à ce rythme là on a
continué à ce rythme là et on a même
accentué le rythme
c'est pas un propos
comment dirais-je secret que je tiens il
est à la tribune du Sénat et Nora Berra
le fait à l'Assemblée nationale donc on
peut pas continuer après s'étonner alors
c'est vrai que l'on dit il y a des
médicaments nouveaux qui sont très chers
oui mais les médicaments matures on en a
besoin également et ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est que les médicaments qui
aujourd'hui posent des problèmes de
disponibilité sont des médicaments qui
sont issus de la chimie à proprement
parler or ce sont ceux-là qui ont fait
l'objet des délocalisations importantes
sauf que c'est pas seulement les
nouveaux traitements dont on a besoin ce
sont aussi les autres donc il y a cette
question de long terme qui couvre
clairement et je répondrai aussi en
partie aux autres questions que vous
posez notamment à la cinquième question
sur saint-exil quel est le problème
qu'il y a il le dit très clairement vu
le prix qui est payé il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui d'intérêt forcément un
relocaliser et puis il y a aussi un
autre sujet si je ne me trompe pas qu'il
avance parce que nous l'avons aidé nous
au niveau de la région à un moment donné
c'est que tout le problème de
l'industrie du médicament c'est aussi ce
qu'il y a comme nouveau médicament dans
les pipes or là comme il n'y avait rien
qui était dans les pailles qui un jour
allait arriver en production il savait
pertinemment que les perspectives
risquaient d'être fatales donc prix et
paille c'est ça qui a fait justement
défaut à saint-exibles mais si on en
revient clairement la question du prix
qui est quand même le cœur du problème
quels sont les solutions c'est
d'accepter que sur un certain nombre de
produits matures si on le veut qu'il y
ait une nouvelle relocalisation y
compris de produits qui sont issus de la
chimie il faut donc on imagine une
nouvelle forme de tarification qui
profitera qui a des PME ADP PME sur le
territoire national parce que ce sont
elles qui seront au cœur de cette
relocalisation ce seront pas les grands
labos les grands labos sont
principalement sur autre chose ils ont
leur stock de produits mature prend
Sanofi avec le paracétamol pour pas dire
le doliprane et sur les nouveaux
traitements mais sur les autres c'est
pas eux qui vont en bénéficier c'est pas
eux parce que regardez aujourd'hui
si je ne me trompe pas en France qui
produit encore des antibiotiques
il y a que Sanofi sont les seuls tout le
reste est parti si vous voulez avoir le
mouvement en sens inverse il faut qu'il
y ait une politique de prix qui soit
élaborée par le CEPS mais je vais
revenir avec le feu vert de Bercy qui
permet justement de mieux valoriser la
rémunération de ces labos qui seront des
entreprises on va dire européenne qui
sont des entreprises françaises avec un
prix qui vient cibler le retour
justement de ces médicaments sur le
territoire national si c'est une mesure
large ça ne fonctionnera pas si c'est
une mesure large pour que les grands
labos reviennent à cela c'est pas
justement ce qu'ils ont en tête et donc
ça doit être très clairement ciblé mais
là madame la rapporteur se pose une
question qui fixe le prix des
médicaments en France
ce que la dichotomie insupportable entre
le ministère de la santé et le ministère
de l'économie des finances et du budget
c'est le fond du problème c'est le fond
du problème j'ai toujours connu ça dans
une vie antérieure ou bien évidemment
c'est dur vous faites le PLFSS mais
aujourd'hui avec la logique des comptes
publics la politique du médicament comme
une bonne partie de la politique de
santé et encore je veux pas parler
d'autres politiques les fêtes à Bercy
avec des raisonnements comptables donc
de court terme comment voulez-vous avoir
une logique d'investissement alors si
parfois vous avez le ministère de
l'Économie et des Finances qui dit que
sur vocation très stratégique des choses
on doit investir oui mais c'est le
contraire qui se fait chaque année et
donc tant qu'on n'a pas une unité une
unité
d'actions de définition de la stratégie
et pardonnez-moi de le dire qui doit
être fixé par le ministère de la Santé
ça ne peut pas marcher ça ne peut pas
marcher parce que bien souvent la santé
le médicament je crois encore une fois
la variable d'ajustement comment
voulez-vous bâtir quelque chose au-delà
des grands discours
donc vous ne pouvez pas avoir le CEPS
d'un côté et les influences qui sont
celles de Bercy sans qu'on aboutisse à
des situations comme celles-ci c'est ça
le fond du problème donc très très
clairement sur la relocalisation je vous
le dis on a très clairement ce besoin de
cibler une politique de prix sur ce type
de médicament là pas surtout pas surtout
pas surtout les produits qui soient une
mesure et il faut aussi l'assumer les
Allemands de se gêne pas pour le faire
qui puisse profiter vraiment à nos PME
celle qui accepteront le consentir
l'effort d'investissement et ensuite
d'avoir accès à un remboursement qui
leur donne une vraie visibilité ce que
vous pouvez favoriser l'investissement
que vous voulez si derrière il y a pas
une solvabilisation du marché ça ne peut
pas fonctionner et dans ces cas-là vous
avez quelque chose qui peut tient la
route et répondre justement au défi ceci
ne nous dispensant pas d'une véritable
politique européenne en la matière parce
que vous avez raison de le souligner
les pénuries touchent l'ensemble des
pays d'Europe et ça ne s'arrêtera pas
parce que aujourd'hui nous avons une
dépendance à l'un des Lachine ok ce qui
nous pendait c'est la dépendance aux
États-Unis dans les années qui viennent
non pas forcément seulement là où
médicament mature mais sur les nouvelles
thérapies parce que c'est ça le problème
de demain les pénuries ne s'arrangeront
pas mais là c'est les États-Unis qui
vont pouvoir dicter le la en matière de
disponibilité sur le marché mondial donc
on peut très bien regarder l'Asie et
l'Inde mais il faut aussi qu'on regarde
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique là où on
a besoin d'une politique européenne
c'est aussi pour qu'on établisse d'une
certaine façon une liste de médicaments
stratégiques aussi au niveau européen
faut de quoi on tombera dans les mêmes
problèmes le seul point sur lequel je
suis pas en divergence avec vous mais
pour bien préciser ma position
il faut bien voir une chose c'est que si
je ne me trompe pas la France est leader
en termes de production de médicaments
en Europe grosso modo de 1995 à 2008
2010 je crois que c'est 2008 aujourd'hui
on est devenu le quatrième producteur de
médicaments en Europe après Suisse
Allemagne - Italie et quatrième
producteur en Europe ça doit faire de
nous le cinquième encore que moi je
pensais qu'on était plus loin que cela
le cinquième au niveau mondial bon sauf
que c'était en début d'année le LEM a
produit une étude comparative nos
médicaments globalement sont 40% moins
cher qu'en Suisse ils sont 33% moins
cher qu'en Allemagne et ils sont 18%
moins cher qu'en Italie je parle pas de
la Grande-Bretagne qui n'est plus dans
l'Union européenne ok qu'est-ce qui se
passe nous avons un nombre de labos qui
ne sont pas par nature des philanthropes
ok bah où est-ce qu'ils mettent leur
médicament priorité là où c'est le plus
rémunérateur pour eux alors je sais bien
que quand on va chez le pharmacien
et de cibler des questions de
rémunération des laboratoires en
fonction des médicaments qu'on aura
estimé comme stratégique et surtout en
fonction du profil des entreprises qui
sont nature à accueillir justement ces
relocalisations alors vous parlez de la
question environnementale très
franchement aujourd'hui je le vois avec
nombre d'industries que nous accueillons
dans la région des Hauts de France on
est capable
de pouvoir montrer que ce soit sur les
émanations ou autres on est capable de
prendre l'ensemble des filtrages
possibles l'ensemble des mesures
protectrices de l'environnement et s'il
y a des préventions nous savons
pertinemment que les enquêtes publiques
et ceux qui nous est demandé au niveau
environnemental ne permet plus de faire
les erreurs qui auraient pu être
commises dans les années 60 et 70 et je
le vois notamment sur des extensions
vous avez parlé dans la région de Sanofi
mais je pense notamment à GSK à
Saint-Amand à strazane sur le
Dunkerquois ça ne pose aucun problème
avec les riverains que de voir des
extensions de sites industriels
pharmaceutiques loin sans faux vous
m'avez aussi parlé de la question des
mesures qui avaient été prises et ce
qu'elles avaient été acceptées alors il
y a deux choses il y a les mesures que
je suis amené à élaborer parce que
la société française a nécessité de
réanimation m'alertent à l'été 2011 sur
la question et le 2 août de Milo est
aussi des associations de patients à
l'époque des associations de patients on
est en amont parce qu'on sur la question
de l'anesthésie de la rédémie
au cœur de la crise covid on a eu un
problème d'alimentation curare on a
failli avoir un vrai problème de
disponibilité durable sur le cura nul
besoin de vous expliquer ici le côté
absolument indispensable du curare pour
pour la réa les problèmes sont encore
devant nous les problèmes sont encore
devant nous sur la seule question du
curare donc à la question l'alerte vient
la société française et les associations
de patients donc moi je le dis aussi
très clairement à l'époque je dans les
médias je dénonce un système
d'importation qui prive les pharmaciens
français d'approvisionnement se sont mes
termes et je me dis prêt à contraindre
l'élaboratoires à respecter leurs
engagements là-dessus j'avais fait
procéder en mars 2011 à des enquêtes et
j'avais mobilisé c'était pas de mon
ressort la DGCCRF sur cette question là
à la suite de la réunion avec l'ensemble
des acteurs le 8 septembre 2011 à
l'époque j'annonce excusez-moi de lire
parce que c'est quand même la 12 ans
donc j'ai un peu vieilli de vieilli
depuis je me souviens plus précisément
on annonce un plan d'action qui est mis
en oeuvre sans délai sans délais c'est
pas pour dans 6 mois sans délai sous
l'égide de la DGS et de la SAPS mais la
DGS je ne délègue pas à la sable ce soin
de tout mettre qui pose d'ailleurs les
questions de gouvernance je vais revenir
dans un instant un on rappelle les
obligations de service public de chacun
des acteurs avec des contrôles on
identifie les zones de risque avec une
liste de classe thérapeutiques définies
à l'époque comme sensible c'est-à-dire
présentant à la fois un intérêt majeur
mais aussi avec un risque de rupture
notamment avec ces questions
d'approvisionnement et la mise en place
d'un suivi national des
approvisionnements de ces produits on
était si je me trompe pas à l'époque sur
les entiers rétroviraux sur les
anesthésiques et on était aussi sur les
anticancéreux je crois que ça doit être
ça on avait un plan de gestion des
pénuries à la charge des titulaires
d'AMM et on avait mis aussi en place un
circuit d'information rapide pour
permettre de signaler toute rupture de
stock potentiel pas seulement avérée
mais aussi potentiellement c'était même
penché sur la question des AR êtes
commercialisation vous savez quand un
labo décide de ne plus commercialiser un
produit comment on fait pour que les
personnes directement concernées et les
prescripteurs puissent mieux s'organiser
et ne pas se retrouver qu'un système de
défaillance justement de traitement ça
ça va plutôt bien bon ma loi dite du 29
décembre 2011 avait recueilli un très
très large un sentiment sur les bancs du
Sénat de l'assemblée
c'était pas tout à fait la même chose
dans le monde pharmaceutique parce que
la loi du médicament imposait des
changements drastiques notamment sur la
question des conflits d'intérêt sur la
question d'intervention du monde
pharmaceutique
dans le financement du monde de la santé
mais là ce qui avait été établi sur
cette partie là ça savait poser moins de
difficultés c'est qu'il y avait toute
une partie un dispositif réglementaire
sur la prévention de la gestion des
ruptures de stock et d'approvisionnement
pas seulement de stock mais aussi
l'approvisionnement le délai
d'information de la NSM auquel est tenue
d'exploiter tenue l'exploitant avant de
suspendre d'arrêter la commercialisation
a été étendue six mois avant à un an
avant parce qu'à l'époque c'était ça qui
nous a inquiétait il y avait un système
d'astreinte pour les grossistes
répartisseurs et il y avait aussi des
obligations de services publics
nouvelles qui avaient été créés pour les
grossistes répartiteurs et en plus tout
manquement à tout cela engageait des
sanctions financières assez assez
importantes donc voilà ce été mis en
place après il y a un sujet vous savez
c'est pas tout à fait nouveau quand
administra arrive toujours un peu
compliqué de reprendre à son compte et à
100% ce qu'un autre ministre a fait on
l'a vu sur des décrets d'application qui
devaient encore être publiées et cela
fait maintenant je dirais les spaghettis
11 ans après
je n'ai pas suivi à la lettre ce qui
s'est passé ensuite mais le problème est
simple je le dis souvent une loi votée
c'est bien une loi appliquée c'est mieux
et après se pose un autre problème que
vous avez pointé du doigt madame la
rapporteur
c'est que qui pilote il y a un mal
français c'est que on a éloigné du
centre de décision politique les centres
d'action et contrôle c'est la question
des agences alors il faut savoir quelle
est la jeunesse de cet agence de ces
agences c'est d'ailleurs l'un des points
sur lesquels quand il y a eu la crise du
médicament j'avais voulu revenir je
pense que la responsabilité politique ne
se délègue pas ne se partage pas elle
appartient propre au ministre et que
même si le ministre ne peut peut-être
pas tout voir et autres il doit
organiser son action de façon à ce que
la responsabilité politique ne soit pas
éloignée du ministère c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous ne pouvez pas
déléguer à la seule agence le soin de
faire les choses il faut que ce soit le
ministère pas forcément le cabinet du
mini surtout aujourd'hui avec les
contraintes effectives dans les cabinets
mais tout simplement que ce soit le
ministère que ce soit les directions du
ministère qui soit tenues de suivre les
choses et de ne pas dire c'est pas moi
ce sont les agences bon maintenant pas
non plus raconter l'histoire c'est aussi
la vision que j'ai tout ça relève de la
presse en contaminée la responsabilité
ministérielle ayant été fortement
engagée il y a eu tout un souci dans les
années 90 pour éloigner niveau de
responsabilité de déléguer des agences
cet appareil fait du hasard on est allé
trop loin là-dedans parce que les gens
ne comprennent pas qu'il n'y ait aucune
responsabilité et à les politiques et la
question de la disponibilité des
médicaments relève de l'essence de la
politique de l'anticipation et de la
prise en charge de l'état de santé nos
concitoyens et encore une fois il s'agit
pas de DESS saisir la NSA mais il s'agit
tout simplement qu'il y ait une
véritable surveillance à l'époque qui
avait été mise en place notamment sur la
loi médicament c'est que la liste des
médicaments qui pouvait poser problème
cette liste là ce soit le ministre qui
régulièrement et à se prononcer dessus
ou que ce soit en sa présence de façon
encore une fois à ne pas éloigner le
centre de décision c'est ça dont on
souffre aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne comprennent
pas un qu'on soit dans le déni non non
il y a pas de pénurie ou alors si on a
un léger problème de rupture de stock
Ock vous inquiétez pas dans 15 jours
c'est réglé enfin c'est plutôt tous les
15 jours qu'on a les mêmes déclarations
plutôt qu'on a les solutions et c'est ça
qui pose aujourd'hui le véritable le
véritable problème donc voilà un peu le
regard que j'ai donc est-ce qu'il faut
enlever à la NSM non mais pas la seule à
NSM le contrôle doit être politique et
politique c'est le ministère encore une
fois pas le seul cabinet mais le
ministère
je vais peut-être pas répondu à tout
mais dans ces cas-là vous vous
n'hésiterez pas à me réinterroger mais
j'ai essayé de prendre effectivement à
la volée vos remarques et vos questions
merci beaucoup donc je vais pas passer
la parole au collège
merci monsieur le ministre de l'ensemble
de ses propos auxquels j'adhère
complètement je voudrais revenir sur sur
un des points que vous avez abordé c'est
celui de l'effort demandé à l'industrie
pharmaceutique
c'est un effort qui est considérable et
c'est surtout un effort qui est
inconstant
d'une année sur l'autre les efforts sont
différents ce qui fait que les
entreprises internationales nationales
ne peuvent pas faire de prévisions
budgétaire sauf à la fin de l'année et
parfois les directeurs nationaux sont
obligés d'être dire à leur directeur
internationaux on me demande par un
milliard cette année mais 700 millions
et après on me demande pas un milliard
mais un milliard 8 et ça l'inconstance
crée des problèmes majeurs au niveau de
l'industrie pharmaceutique je voudrais
revenir sur la composition du CEPS aussi
je crois qu'il est en effet important et
je vous rejoins complètement ça m'embête
de dire vous mais là on est en officiel
donc je vous rejoins complètement
il faudrait que dans le CEPS le
ministère de la santé soit dominant
alors pour l'instant c'est Bercy qui est
dominant dans la composition
dans la composition des fonctionnaires
du représentant les ministériales la
recherche l'industrie les le budget
l'économie le budget ou l'économie et la
santé et la santé c'est le nombre de
fonctionnaires le moins important à
l'intérieur du CEPS donc il est
important que le CEPS voit sa
recomposition faite au profit de la
santé et je crois que sur ce sujet je
vous rejoins complètement j'ai une
petite question
lorsque l'agence européenne donne un
avis positif sur un nouveau médicament
est-il
utile que la NSM l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament française
toutes les études afin de dire si ce
médicament est acceptable ou pas et
qu'ensuite après la NSM la HAS elle-même
disent peut-être que oui peut-être que
non
on perd un temps fou par rapport à
d'autres pays par rapport à l'Allemagne
par rapport à la Belgique est-ce que
c'est vraiment utile que les avis de
agence européenne soit reconsidérées par
des agences nationales
la rapporteur
qui vient de poser une question
ce qui est l'usage c'est que je
distribue la parole aux différents
sénateurs et donc je pense que vous
pourrez tout à fait répondre par une
question si vous le souhaitez même si ça
nous empêchera pas d'exiger une réponse
à un moment
Laurence Harris
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
ministre mais revenir sur deux trois
petites choses que vous avez dites pour
avoir un éclairage supplémentaire
vous vous plaidez finalement pour une
revalorisation de du prix du médicament
en particulier les médicaments mature
d'autant plus que
vous soulignez que ça profiterait au PME
et c'est quelque chose qui ressort de
nos auditions où on sent bien finalement
qu'on est passé d'un marché de masse un
marché de niche et que de fait
l'industrie pharmaceutique est en train
de s'organiser sur ces deux types de
marchés donc on vous suivrait assez
facilement mais la préoccupation c'est
de vérifier que c'est effectivement
les PME qui vont en bénéficier sachant
que l'industrie pharmaceutique est très
fragmenté et que si on prend un exemple
peut-être que je me trompe mais comme
biogaran qui est dans le top 10 des
médicaments génériques et des l'une des
premières entreprises françaises et
qu'on pourrait considérer finalement
comme quelqu'un qui pourrait être
accompagné dans cette production là
c'est quand même une filiale de Servier
donc il y a un un moment donné on sent
bien que les équilibres sont pas
garantis donc qu'est-ce qui pourrait
garantir ça parce que en même temps on a
bien le sentiment qu'on est à la
charnière de quelque chose et qu'on a
une modification en profondeur de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et puis la
deuxième question parce que je veux pas
monopoliser et d'autres ont certainement
des questions vous parlez d'obligation
de service public on l'a abordé ce matin
avec
avec une autre un autre ministre qui
vous a succédé
c'est bien les obligations de services
publics mais quels sont les moyens de
contrôle et de sanctions et dans votre
expérience même si vous vous avez
finalement innové dans la dans les dans
les procédures et dans la dans cette
vision là peut-être que le recul est pas
assez nécessaire pour savoir comment ça
peut être contrôlé mais en tout cas
comment nous on pourrait faire des
propositions pour garantir cette cet
élément là merci Pascal Bruni
c'est même la présidente monsieur le
ministre j'ai juste complété une chose
dont on parle pas c'est la consommation
des médicaments en France parce que la
pénurie bien sûr elle est partout elle
est plus importante chez nous et quand
on va les consommations d'allemand
d'antibiotiques de psychotropes etc elle
est plus forte en France est-ce que vous
avez un regard sur sur ça
sur sur le les prix du médicament bien
entendu ça c'est vraiment le sujet qui
ressort beaucoup en revanche il y a le
budget de la Sécurité sociale vous avez
parlé de Bercy mais le budget de la
Sécurité sociale qui est quand même est
toujours
déficitaire qu'on a du mal à équilibrer
et qui est encore en visuel je veux dire
on va chercher
dans d'autres budgets pour essayer de
compenser donc c'est vraiment un souci
donc quelle solution quelle solution
et qui doit fin Ancer les stocks
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est c'est
l'entreprise qui doit financer le stock
c'est une des questions que nous sommes
posées avec Laurence haribet parce qu'on
est sur l'Europe du médicament un cada
commission des affaires européennes
parce que le stocks ça coûte cher en
fait si on l'impose aux entreprises et
comme vous avez dit en plus j'ai bien
retenu que finalement on leur avait déjà
demandé beaucoup si on leur demande en
plus ça voilà merci
Emilienne Pomerol
oui merci le président de mon monsieur
le ministre parler du prix puisque on
sent bien au fil des auditions que c'est
un des problèmes majeurs et vous
interroger un petit peu sur la
transparence des prix du médicament on a
questionné à plusieurs reprises les
différentes
institutions et les labos on a pu
rencontrer on a du mal à savoir quel est
le prix de revient comment il est pris
en compte comment est pris en compte
éventuellement la recherche et
développement et en particulier la
recherche fondamentale et la recherche
publique qui participent à ce prix et si
je suis d'accord avec vous pour dire que
effectivement merci à une place
certainement beaucoup trop importante
par rapport au ministère de la Santé
comment on peut mieux
j'allais dire donner des critères sur
l'établissement des prix et je pense
vous avez beaucoup parlé des prix des
médicaments matures qui effectivement
ont été rongeront j'ai rangé mais
quid du prix comment fixe-t-on
aujourd'hui le prix de ce médicament
innovants les biothérapies
thérapiegéniques qui atteignent des
sommes exorbitantes comment on peut les
justifier comment on peut les contrôler
oui moi j'ajouterai à cette question
budgétaire le fait que quand on a
auditionné
la CNAM
il y a trois axes que qui sont qui
sous-tendent les choix stratégiques de
la CNAM et dans les trois axes il y a la
soutenabilité donc la dimension
budgétaire est mise quasiment au même
niveau que la dimension sanitaire et que
on parle beaucoup de Bercy mais en
réalité c'est à toutes les échelles et
notamment en matière de politique du
médicament que c'est considérations
budgétaire se décline et donc est-ce
qu'il y a pas aussi de ce point de vue à
réfléchir sur les orientations et
peut-être cette idée un peu un peu
comment dire permanente que nous avons
de plusieurs années de trivialement
comme on dit boucher le trou de la Sécu
alors qu'en réalité on est bien dans des
politiques de santé publique et que on
doit déborder ce cadre là voilà je vous
remercie
je vous laisse prendre
la transparence du prix du médicament va
ce sujet parce que derrière vous avez
toujours le secret des affaires je ne
sais pas comment les choses se passent
encore aujourd'hui moi j'ai connu dans
mes fonctions ministérielles notamment
un grand patron du CEPS qui était Noël
Renaudin et qui rentrait à chaque fois
dans des vrais discussions négociations
avec les labos il y avait besoin de
savoir ça il y avait la question des
prix pratiqués dans d'autres pays en
Europe et ça renvoie aussi à la question
que vous évoquiez la question de la
lisibilité de la visibilité quand on
était aussi à avoir des discussions en
la matière beaucoup de centres de
décision qu'il était pas en France pour
des laboratoires étrangers nous disait
la France marché est important dépense
de santé se situe un niveau important du
PIB mais c'est impossible d'avoir des
prévisions parce qu'en fonction de tel
ou tel amendement même gouvernemental
dans un PLFSS toute notre stratégie
d'investissement d'industrialisation
peut-être remise en cause et on a la
dernière difficulté avec vous en France
avoir une vision même pas de long terme
mais une vision de moyen terme donc et
se poser aussi la question en France
comme il n'y a pas de politique
également de moyens et long terme et
comme nous voulions avoir accès aux
médicaments les plus innovants c'est
quand même un peu moins le cas
aujourd'hui on n'a pas forcément la
garantie d'avoir tout de suite les
médicaments les plus innovants c'était
ça la difficulté donc il y a une partie
de secret des affaires mais il y a une
partie avec des vrais professionnels
d'avoir un regard sur ce qui correspond
prix et vous sentez aussi dans une
négociation ce quel point de rupture ou
ce qui n'est pas le point de rupture
tout ce que je vous dis là remonte
maintenant à plus de 15 années je ne
sais pas exactement comment les choses
se font aujourd'hui mais ce que je sais
c'est que quand on a un regard purement
budgétaire ça peut pas réussir ça c'est
sûr et certain alors attendez je vous
dis ça j'ai quand même eu à conduire au
départ sur l'autorité de Philippe
Doussaud Blasi et ensuite dans ma
responsabilité ministériale a conduit
une réforme de l'assurance maladie sur
laquelle personne n'aurait parié un
centime d'euro à l'époque sur ce
résultat elle a produit plus de
résultats d'économies qu'il n'y en avait
au départ dans les objectifs de la
réforme parce qu'encore une fois une loi
voté c'est bien il doit appliquer c'est
mieux une réforme engagée c'est bien une
réforme suivie des faits c'est mieux et
donc nous avions réussi justement à le
faire donc je sais que dans la vie il
faut savoir compter surtout quand on est
responsable public mais encore une fois
pas en oubliant les impératifs Swan
investissement soit les impératifs de
santé publique et ça nous renvoie aussi
à une autre à une autre question que
poser la sénatrice Pascal gruni je
souris parce que
la vie présidente la vice-présidente du
Sénat Pascal grunis c'est que tout ça
nous conduit à quel modernisation du
système de santé
je pense que aujourd'hui vous voyez dans
nos services publics il va y avoir des
investissements importants à faire il y
a peut-être des services publics sur
lesquels c'est pas une question de
moyens supplémentaires sur la santé on
échappera pas la question des moyens
supplémentaires c'est pas on peut se
raconter tout ce que l'on veut ça sera
pas possible pourquoi parce qu'il y aura
la question des thérapies innovantes qui
coûtent de plus en plus cher et un pays
comme la France ne peut pas voir dans
d'autres pays les médicaments innovants
sur le marché et les plus riches d'entre
nous être capable de les acheter sur
Internet ou à l'étranger pendant que les
autres qui auront pas accès et ça va
continuer et l'autre part nous savons
pertinemment que les investissements
dans les personnels vont rester une
priorité au-delà des Ségur au delà des
Ségur alors bien sûr qu'il y a des
économies la cellatrice c'est notamment
sur la question des actes redondants les
actes redondants donc toujours pas
baissé à l'époque déjà on parlait d'un
milliard et demi d'euros bon ils sont
effectués ils sont pratiqués ils sont
pas des faux-ac mais ce qui peut aussi
la question de la pertinence des actes
déjà d'un point de vue médical et
ensuite au niveau du coût de la sécurité
sociale mais même s'il y a des gisements
d'économie ça n'est pas à des besoins en
financement dans le système de santé
dans les années qui viennent c'est le
service public qui aujourd'hui a le
besoin le plus d'engager d'engager des
moyens donc nous n'y échas nous n'y
échapperons pas la question c'est de
savoir sur quoi on met les priorités et
la question des produits de santé fait
partie bien évidemment clairement de ces
priorités il y a la question la question
des consommations des médicaments il y a
à la fois la pertinence des traitements
il y a la observance des traitements et
puis il y a aussi la question également
de l'explosion des épidémies sans même
parler du covid qui a aussi généré vous
le disiez tout à l'heure madame leur
rapporteur dans les éléments
multifactoriels de la pénurie il y a
aussi ça on a été confronté à des
difficultés avec un état général de
santé de la population qui a nécessité
également davantage de médicaments mais
quand même remarquons quand même que
nous sommes toujours l'un des pays les
plus consommateurs nos médicaments
anxiolytique pour être plus précis par
rapport à des pays comme les Pays-Bas la
comparaison n'a pas besoin d'être
développée beaucoup plus est-ce que
c'est l'un des éléments en partie est-ce
que ça explique la pénurie à proprement
parler non mais dans un environnement
multifactoriel oui effectivement cela
est nature et nature à jouer à jouer
beaucoup mais sur la question du
financement des stocks
une PME peut pas financer tous les
stocks
et là la question se pose quel est le
rôle de la puissance publique et pardon
quel est le rôle de la puissance
publique au niveau européen parce que si
on constitue des stocks au niveau
européen là il faut savoir ce que l'on
veut j'estime que c'est aussi au niveau
européen clairement que la question doit
se poser une PME ne pourra pas financer
des stocks ou faire le tampon comme
c'est comme c'est le cas pour un grand
labo d'où l'idée aujourd'hui de
différencier et si je peux me permettre
si je peux me permettre c'est vous-même
madame la sénatrice qu'il est qu'il
évoquait tout à l'heure je pense que sur
la question du prix aujourd'hui on a un
élastique qui se tend entre les grands
labos et les génériqueurs et et au
milieu il y a les entreprises dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et là où je suis
d'accord c'est que le problème n'est pas
de financer biogaran sur des
investissements là la question j'ai dit
tout à l'heure il y a deux leviers
d'action il y a le financement des
investissements
et on peut très bien prendre des volumes
de chiffres d'affaires ou autre ayant
ensuite la solvabilisation du marché par
les prix et une entreprise comme
biogaran s'il décidait notamment de
relocaliser c'est avec les prix sur le
marché qu'ils peuvent s'y retrouver mais
là on n'a pas besoin de faire le même
effort d'investissement que pour une PME
vous voyez si bien que ça évite d'être
logé exactement la même enseigne que les
PME dont on a besoin de redensifier
notre territoire et qui plus est ça va
intéresser beaucoup de territoires de
pouvoir justement bénéficier de cette
relocalisation dont on parle davantage
que on en envoie aujourd'hui les fruits
faut dire les choses telles faut le dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont
notamment dans le souffrance les
phénomènes qui ont été vus où sont des
phénomènes il y a encore une fois à des
grands labos c'est bien mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que pour répondre à nos
questions de pénurie aujourd'hui la clé
la clé du problème n'est pas encore
celle là donc sur les stocks ça peut pas
être des PME qui financent puissance
publique oui mais là au niveau européen
je pense que ça a du sens exige j'en
reviens à la question que vous évoquiez
je pense qu'il faut que très clairement
l'assumer on veut de la souveraineté
industrielle en matière pharmaceutique
ok alors faut qu'il y ait un bonus
souveraineté
le bonus souveraineté on le décompose
aide massive à l'investissement ou
solvabilisation du marché avec une
répartition qui peut être liée au niveau
du chiffre d'affaires pour éviter qu'il
y ait un effet d'aubaine ou de double
aubaine pour certains mais clairement
c'est un bonus souveraineté qu'il faut
très clairement mettre en place si on
veut le faire si je peux me permettre
comment se fait-il que les gouvernements
n'est pas lu à l'époque le rapport du
Sénat sur la question comment se fait-il
que les gouvernements s'éveuvent
aujourd'hui les pénuries alors même
qu'il y a une proposition de loi qui
avait été déposée si je ne me trompe pas
en août 21 par un sénateur un sénateur
j'avais pas dire des hauts transmets un
sénateur du Nord et tout est dedans tout
est dedans pourquoi ils l'ont pas lu
pourquoi le ministère de la Santé n'a
pas lieu pas bien l'application c'était
si je me trompe pas une PPL avec très
articles c'était un rapport d'une
commission avec une trentaine de
recommandations elles ont pas pris une
ride hélas elles auraient gagné elles
auraient gagné à être rendu absolument
concrète et opérationnel qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont attendu qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
attendu c'est tout le problème
d'ailleurs on voit bien dans notre pays
ce qui a nombreuses solutions qui sont
sur la table empirique concrètes parce
que vous interrogez qui vous interrogez
l'ancien ministre interroger des
responsables publics et je suis certain
que vous faites comme je faisais quand
j'étais ministre avant de préparer cette
audition vous avez interrogé des acteurs
de terrain notamment des pharmaciens qui
vous expliquent facilement les choses
qui vous expliquerai facilement les
choses et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui les leçons sont là
il y a un vrai problème d'anticipation
il y a une question de prix et ensuite
c'est si on veut clairement passer à la
phase de relocalisation et de
souveraineté est-ce qu'on met en place
oui ou non un bonus souveraineté et vers
qui on le flèche en priorité
pardon juste un point juste un point vos
motorisez ma question madame la
Présidente
Monsieur le Sénateur
has ansm vers qui pencherait votre
préférence
oui moi aussi non je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est parce que là on est
clairement sur une dimension
médical de chez médical le vrai problème
pourquoi est-ce qu'on multiplie les
procédures en France
pourquoi on multiplie les procédures
plus les procédures sont longues plus de
temps vous mettez admettre un médicament
remboursement et pendant ce temps-là
l'assurance maladie des bourses pas oui
le système je le dis très clairement a
été mis en place en France de telle
façon que plus vous tardez moins vous
dépensez d'argent tout de suite
d'un système qui malthusianiste
mais pardon c'est le même problème dans
les autorisations d'établissement de
santé ou l'établissement pour personnes
âgées plus les procédures tardent moins
vous avez dépenses à fonctionner parce
qu'on n'a jamais eu le courage de dire
que clairement nous n'avions pas les
moyens de pouvoir mettre en place toutes
les politiques nécessaires et en matière
de médicaments ça a été le cas des
médicaments tarde à être admis sur le
marché à être admis au remboursement
parce que pendant ce temps-là ce sont
des mois qui sont gagnés
et le système a fonctionné comme ça
pendant bien longtemps pendant bien
longtemps certains ministres ont
accéléré des procédures peut-être pu le
reprocher des moments donnés mais c'est
aussi l'une des clés n'osent pas dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont malgré
toutes les sommes que l'on débourse
notre système de santé d'assurance
maillet est insuffisamment financée on
ne veut pas regarder suffisamment le
poids des ALD on ne peut pas voir le
vieillissement de la population le fait
que l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
diminue et aujourd'hui qu'on est
justement les pénuries de médicaments
parce qu'en matière de santé l'un des
enjeux c'est la prévention en matière
politique c'est l'anticipation
alors je reviens juste sur un point que
vous aviez évoqué tout à l'heure les
Prusse à l'époque quand il est mis en
place
j'ai Prusse quand il est mis en place ne
veuille pas se préparer uniquement à la
question justement de la pandémie
grippal sur H5 N1 mais vise aussi à
pouvoir se doter mesure d'anticipation
pour constituer des stocks y compris de
médicaments y compris de produits de
santé y compris de matériel notamment
sur qui permettent l'injection de
produits seringues et autres c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait que à l'époque
quand il y a eu H1N1
ma successeur je crois n'a manqué de
rien n'a manqué de rien mais les Prusse
a disparu un jour il a été non pas
remplacé il était fondu dans un ensemble
plus grand
sur les Prusse parce que je suis
complètement d'accord avec le président
des Hauts de France je voudrais lui dire
que dans le même temps où les Prusse a
disparu les NVS a disparu exactement de
Weiss sanitaire qui était extrêmement
important et qui permettait avec des
médecins vigilants un peu partout sur le
territoire national d'être prévenu de ce
qui pouvait se passer et c'est à la
lumière de ce que j'avais pu vivre avec
la crise du chikungunya et de la dingue
quand c'était aperçu que l'InVS avait
besoin de clarifier ses missions devoir
renforcer ses prérogatives mais de
pouvoir faire cette veille stratégique
je voulais quand même rebondir sur la
chaise et
la NSM et aussi la relation comment dire
au budget et à la masse budgétaire qui
est consenti par la puissance publique
pour pouvoir pour rembourser le
médicament ou le prendre en compte il y
a aussi un sujet qui est pas celui de la
pénurie en direct mais on voit bien que
tout ça est quand même très que c'est
finalement le budget qui contre le cadre
puisque les autorisations de mise sur le
marché et notamment les indications sont
pas forcément les mêmes que dans
d'autres pays européens et qu'on a
tendance à avoir des des indications
moins larges pour avoir moins
d'indications remboursables pour
certaines pathologies et ça aussi c'est
un sujet qui qui est pas celui de la
pénurie mais quelque part vis-à-vis de
nos voisins européens est une forme de
pénurie puisqu'on n'a pas accès aux
médicaments remboursé dans la même
situation
de besoin thérapeutiques madame la
présidence que vous me permettrait de
saisir au bon ce que venez de dire
les Allemands ont augmenté de 50% les
prix pour les médicaments thérapeutiques
majeurs
ils l'ont fait ils l'ont fait et
médicament thérapeutique majeur ce ne
sont pas seulement les dernières
innovations
oui mais il y a aussi les caisses
pardonnez-moi il y a les caisses de
prévoyance et notamment les caisses
régionales les caisses régionales bien
évidemment mais au final ils ont
augmenté de 50 % et à partir du moment
où ils augmentent de 50 % ils sont
attractifs ça ne règle pas tout mais il
y a ça quand même
je vous remercie beaucoup de cet
échangeur et de ces de ces réponses très
fournies monsieur le ministre je avant
de lever la séance avec d'autres
éléments qui vous viennent à l'esprit
dans l'immédiat parce que c'est un sujet
l'écureur la France en produit toujours
pas
non produit toujours pas excusez-moi
d'insister là-dessus je suis venu
là-dessus sur la question de 2011 ça
m'avait profondément marqué en visitant
des établissements au coeur de la crise
covid vous savez quel est le besoin
essentiel on est aujourd'hui
mi-2023 l'écura on en produit toujours
pas en France ce qui veut donc dire sur
quelque chose de clé
on est toujours dépendant d'importation
même si les hôpitaux civils de Lyon en
ont fabriqué pendant la crise de la
covid en reconstituant la monographie
qui n'existait plus et en ayant donc
remis en place la recette quelque part
pour pouvoir reconstituer la fabrication
je peux rebondir encore une fois madame
la Présidente ceux qui montrent bien que
dans les situations de crise ce sont les
soignants qui ont su s'adapter et faire
tenir le système comment se fait-il que
hors crise on ne soit pas capable
d'aborder la même logique non pas pour
produire du cura mais tout simplement de
montrer que on doit tirer les
enseignements tout le problème que l'on
a dans notre pays je l'ai dit pour 2011
je l'ai dit pour la loi médicament c'est
est-ce que l'on tire vraiment les
enseignements vous vous le faites vous
vous le faites mais derrière ceux qui
ont la responsabilité exécutive ils le
font ou pas ou est-ce qu'il cède à la
dernière sirène médiatique
au dernier instantané les réseaux
sociaux
voilà pour ces auditions de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur la
pénurie de médicaments c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi et
continuer à suivre l'actualité politique
et parlementaire sur notre site internet
publique sénat.fr je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée sur Public Sénat
[Musique]